you're in the matrix of mind here I can  only use mind to describe the thing  that's making this infinite labyrinth of  your own mind that you're lost in you  you've you've forgotten who you really  are are walking around this labyrinth of  your own mind thinking it's physical  material objects outside of that mind  and I'm wondering oh man why does it  hurt when I stop by toe and why is this  so hard and why is so difficult and  because consciousness is infinite you  can do whatever it wants but it wants to  know these limitations the purpose of  life right now is then okay if this  consciousness is ignoring itself on  purpose then the purpose is to know  these limitations